c'est en 2005 edwards siaka a tiré sa
révérence devant un parlement unanimes à
saluer le parcours de ce jamaïcain
d'origine libanaise à l'époque du haut
de ses 75 ans le chef incontesté du jlp
y prenait sa retraite politique après 43
ans passés à la tête de la même
circonscription celle difficile de west
kingston
[Musique]
depuis ma première élection en 1962 j'ai
passé 10 scrutins successifs pour un
total de quarante trois années avant que
je ne prenne la retraite c'est dans les
quartiers difficiles de l'ouest de
kingston qui edward seaga s'est fait une
réputation en politique
des poches de pauvreté gangréné par la
délinquance et la violence pour
s'imposer voir si haga s'appuie sur les
gangs armés le climat est à la violence
politique émeutes et fusillades se
succèdent
les campagnes électorales sont
sanglantes je dois vous prévenir que
nous avons prévu des manifestations de
masse de nos circonscriptions et celles
ci seront encore plus violents nous
oblige quoi des forces de police à
prendre des mesures radicales dans les
années 70 une véritable guerre civile
fait rage entre ses partisans et ceux de
michael m'emmener le premier ministre de
l'époque à l'élection 1980 on dénombre
près de 800 morts
edward seaga remporte le scrutin face à
m'emmener qui apparaît comme pro cubains
aux yeux de washington
edward siag ami personnel de ronald
regan impose une politique néo libérale
et pro américaine il dirige la jamaïque
durant neuf ans avant que son adversaire
de toujours michael m'emmener ne
revienne aux affaires en 1981
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
edward seaga quand tu es en vain durant
ces années de reconquérir le pouvoir
il a dû se contenter de ses succès dans
sa circonscription de washington dont il
est resté le maître absolu jusqu'à la
fin ce que l'on sait moins de cet homme
controversé
c'est qu'il a été dans les années 1950
un producteur de musique et l'un des
initiateurs du ska ce style musical né à
la jamaïque
[Musique]